say you saw a little bucket of uterus or
a bucket of not uterus but what's that
placenta right if you saw a little
placenta on the ground like Ugh look if
you didn't know it was placenta say
you're walking by you'll be like oh my
God you seen live placenta a
hippopotamus sneezed over here no dude
when I saw placenta for the first time
when my wife gave birth
it's an alien like that is not of this
world it's the it's the craziest thing
you've ever seen and it's just they just
grow that man they can just do that it's
an organ that they grow and then and
then eject it's nuts who does it who
does what grows it well I mean I'm
assuming like it's something you know
the DNA it's like you know once you get
once you're pregnant it just sort of it
just you their body's not oh women who
did you think I said I don't know I
thought someone was growing it somewhere
Placida farmer and he invited me over
and it was just you they grow it in
aquariums lots of jizz it's basically
cheese and honey and like you know
depending like everyone has a different
recipe yeah you have a bunch of there's
a bunch of Asians beating the rice off
of it out in like little boats there's
all kinds of ways to make Placida Theo
these days especially my grandmother's
placenta recipe is insane oh yeah dude
that yeah I've had yeah yeah I've had
plus it's like just depends on the
holiday oh my god when you get a
wonderful Placida it's just so it's so
great harder to find these days I don't
mean to be like an old man and complain
but when I was younger you would get
like much better placenta oh the
Christmas placenta my grandparents would
bring over
oh my God the smell of fresh placenta
bubbling on the stove
Cinnamon's roasting on an open fire god
it was good and my grandmother would put
cinnamon on hers are you kidding me
it's so interesting man it's so
interesting yeah so this was like a big
in my family over Christmas dinner my
grandma my grandfather was like why
don't we add cinnamon to the placenta
and like my grandmother just started
weeping and walked out of the room so
ever since then I've been afraid to try
it but I've heard it gets you super high
yeah it's a real uh I mean it's brought
families together for years I think yeah
I think it's an American tradition I
don't know why people are against it
it's just like what you can you can
adapt you can adjust yeah have you ever
read grapes or wrath dude if we that
book was a half chapter away from them
eating a bowl of boiled placenta that's
right yeah just eat it eat the placenta
eat whatever you want I mean the last
page of that book They're breastfeeding
off their own
sibling I think because they were so
starving in that book well I mean did
you hear like when they recovered Jim
Morrison's body in the bathtub in Paris
his mouth was full of placenta a lot of
people think it was heroin that killed
him but like he got high and choke
dumpless in it oh like Parisian placenta
which is good oh yeah I'm not it sounds
snobby but the I don't think anything
beats the placenta of France yeah
you sound exactly like someone serving
placenta in Paris you've done this
you've been on the placenta tours I want
to know hopeless in a bike door repairs
I was first week of my life
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one